Yeah. And, and I think that, um, you know,
so like shoulder to shoulder person a
person, I feel like a bit of a disconnect,
you know?
But social media,
like we get to share information
sometimes not good information,
sometimes good information,
like the fact that people
are communicating I think
is important. Um, it's,
it's making people take stands on
things that they're all finding out. Oh,
you believe that too? Or I think that
too, like cool. Like I can find my people,
you know? But on the actual
like oxytocin, like social side,
people actually getting
to know each other,
like those like intimate relationships.
Like I feel like that part is,
is suffering a little bit from it.
I think that suffering a little bit in
real life because people were in cars,
they're in traffic,
they're isolated than they go to work
and they're in a cubicle all day and
they'd get home. They're in their
apartment or their house. Yeah.
There's not a lot of like interaction
with people and just think this is just a
side effect of modern life. You know?
It's weird that there's so many,
like in La,
there's so many people next to each other
and almost nobody knows their neighbor.
It's very strange.
What I'm talking about is I think
countries are stupid like states.
I think countries like states,
like I think we should build a wall over
Florida before we should build a wall
for Mexico. I mean, I mean
Florida is a state, right?
But Florida is just as alien as like
say Finland or something like that.
I mean it's just,
just the fact that you can move out of
Florida and they're like, fuck Florida,
man, I'm going to, I'm going to move to
Atlanta. And he'd go up there and like,
nobody stops you. You just go. But if
you're in Tiawana like you like no dog,
there's a fence up here, pitch like
this. No, there's no crossing did.
To me that seems like super fucking
strange and almost like guaranteeing that
those spots are fucked forever.
And the only way those anything's ever
going to level out is if you let anybody
travel wherever they want.
And nobody's willing to do that because
it might fuck up the good spots.
Like la Jolla would be like, no,
no, no. You can't just like, yeah,
you can't just come over from,
I mean you think about it,
La Jolla has some of the wealthiest
real estate in the world, right?
And unbelievable.
Beautiful views.
And you could walk to Mexico
from La Jolla. You could walk,
I mean, what's the distance between
Tijuana and La Jolla? Let's guess.
Let me guess. I'm gonna
say it's 50 miles. Is it 50
I'm going to say 50 no, I, it's not that
many cause it's already depending on,
oh yeah. I would say it's
a 30 minute drive. Like,
like moderate, normal speed
limit. No traffic. 35 yeah,
maybe.
So maybe it's 30 miles.
So it's like a marathon or a marathon run.
Which people do.
They run it all.
They run marathons all top 2030 to 32
miles 30 so you're in fucking tier one or
you were in a third world country and
one of the worst neighborhoods of a third
world country and 32 miles away.
You have like these unbelievable mansions
on these bluffs overlooking the ocean,
like Nigga, that shit.
That's crazy. That's crazy.
And Auto, it's very weird.
Yeah, exactly. It's very weird.
Yeah. And I, and yeah,
that corn, Otto the island,
that's all super wealthy people.
Right?
That's where Dick Cheney lives apparently.
Yeah. They, they have the ability
of shutting that whole island down.
If there's like vandalism or like,
cause it's,
it's got its entry and it's out like,
um,
what is it called? The way.
So it's not exactly an island,
like it does attach to the land. What does
that call to peninsula? Yeah. Yeah. So,
but they have an ability at both the
peninsula edge and the bridge to shut it
down as a community.
If Shit's going down on the island and
they don't want someone to get off.
Wow. Yeah. That's how rich they are. Yeah.
It's only one of the wealthiest
places in the world. And another one,
there's a one off side off of Miami.
There's like some little tiny island
that's filled only with rich people star,
I think so. It was called. Yeah.
It's like one of the most
wealthy places on the planet.
It's one little spot off Miami just
filled with rich folks waiting for a
hurricane to fuck up though.
Is that it?
Star island is a tiny neighborhood
of massive houses and drama. Oh,
there's drama. Oh, see the
big x on it. Like fuck this
place. Okay. It's not a drama.
Damn bad ass houses though. But
they have good brunch to, yeah,
that's a little too, so they have a little
bridge and it's a little tiny island.
All right. Good luck people.
Weird people are weird cat.
That's not safe. Nothing feels safe. Not
in Miami. Pirate. A pirate. Come wipe.
That whole thing that owls,
the place is filled with pirates
that places filled with weird shit.
It's just Florida is so straight. I love
it. I'm joking around, but I hate it.
But I love Miami. I just, it's so strange.
It's such a, every time I go down there,
I'm like, you should have
to have a passport to come
here. This is not America.
I don't give a fuck what anybody says.
It's great, but it's, it's chaos.
But then there's some Florida spots
like we like, okay, Pensacola,
you just go fuck yourself.
Would you say it's basically Alabama
as wealthy? It might as well we,
other than Roy Jones Jr, I
mean, he came out of there.
You put pence coal on the map.